everyone will remember stan lee as the
lovable grandpa of the marvel universe
are you tony's stank all those wonderful
cameos aside
stan lee was a cornerstone of the comics
industry dating all the way back to
1939.
for eight decades lee compiled a
remarkable list of achievements and
changed comics forever but there's still
plenty that many marvel fans don't know
about his life and legacy
let's take some time to remember and
appreciate stan lee for introducing us
to earth's mightiest heroes
stan lee was born stanley martin lieber
in 1922 which was perfect timing to
enter the workforce during the great
depression
he was always interested in writing and
when he turned 18 he got a job with
timely comics
the company that would later become
marvel it just happened to be owned by
martin goodman who was married to lee's
cousin
how much this family connection helped
lee get the job remains disputed
at the time lee assumed his career in
comics would be short-lived
and worried that it might hurt his
ambition to become a respected novelist
as a result he adopted stan lee as a pen
name and spent years introducing himself
to people simply as a writer
without telling them what he wrote lee
had been working at marvel for less than
a year when joe simon and jack kirby
discovered that martin goodman had been
stiffing them out of royalties on their
popular creation captain america
outraged kirby and simon quit timely for
national comics the company that would
later become dc
goodman immediately appointed the 19
year old stan lee to replace simon as
editor-in-chief
at the time he had mostly written short
filler comics and brief text stories
that were only included so the comics
could get a cheaper rate on postage
according to lee the appointment was
supposed to be temporary but goodman
became distracted with other branches of
his publishing company
and forgot to replace him as it turned
out lee remained in the post for the
next
three decades although like most comics
creators of his generation he did take a
few years out to serve in the army
during world war
ii it was there that he had his greatest
fame as an artist
designing posters warning soldiers
against sexually transmitted diseases
with the catchy caption vd not me
after the war superheroes suffered a
shockingly rapid decline in popularity
and over a timely all superhero comics
were cancelled
lee desperate to stay in business had
little room for creativity
despite efforts to copy other company's
success with westerns and monster comics
the company repeatedly risked bankruptcy
during the 1950s to the point that jack
kirby said he once came in to find lee
sobbing while movers were taking
furniture out of the office
goodman eventually made lee fire all the
other employees including many of his
closest friends
but kept lee himself around when lee was
39 he told his wife joan that he wanted
to quit
but dc had recently reinvigorated
superhero comics with their new team
book the justice league of america
in an attempt to replicate those sales
lee and jack kirby co-created the
fantastic four
a huge hit that saved the company and
changed comics history
with steve ditko stan had co-created
spider-man and doctor strange
but by the mid-60s their relationship
had deteriorated to the point of being
almost non-existent
ditko had always been a little intense
but as his tenure on amazing spider-man
continued
he attempted to inject the stories with
references to ein rand's objectivist
philosophy
in which he was an ardent believer that
put him at odds with lee
and eventually they stopped speaking to
each other even as they continued
working on the comic
the final straw came when the two
creators disagreed over the true
identity of the green goblin
lee wanted it to be norman osborne the
father of spider-man's best friend
ditko allegedly wanted the goblin to be
an unrelated criminal
lee won the argument ditko exited the
book and was replaced by john romita
senior who stayed with marvel many years
despite their disputes lee and ditko
were two forces to be reckoned with
and both left us in the same year ditko
passed away on june 29th of a heart
attack at the age of 90
while lee followed a few months later on
november 12th at the age of 95.
on the page stan lee and jack kirby may
have been the team responsible for
building the majority of the marvel
universe and telling some of the best
comic book stories of all time
but behind the scenes kirby's
frustration with his collaborator was
growing throughout the 60s
to kirby stan was the consummate
corporate creator serving as the
editor-in-chief in the public face of
the company that kirby saw as exploiting
his talent
when he started at dc kirby wasted no
time in making his feelings known by
turning his collaborator
turned nemesis into a comics character
in the pages of mr miracle number six
kirby introduced funky flashman telling
readers i know him
you know him but does anybody need him
accompanied by a sniveling minion named
house roy thought to be based on stan's
assistant roy thomas
flashman was a con man out to exploit
others talent
and was first seen taking an allowance
that was automatically dispensed from a
statue
literally pulling the money out of
someone else's head despite the bad
blood kirby and lee were able to make
peace in 1993 shortly before kirby's
passing
i don't think there's any artist in the
field today who doesn't owe jack
something
in the 1960s marvel was just a small
division of a company called magazine
management and they weren't actually the
most profitable part of the company
that honor went to a line of men's
magazines with extremely creative names
like stag
mail and complete man sensing an
opportunity to capitalize on that
success
lee decided to combine magazine
management's two most prominent
departments
the result was the adventures of
pussycat which made its debut in 1965 as
what lee called
a nudie cutie comic oh
man while lee's gamble on the adventures
of pussycat didn't really pay off the
scandalous story included work from lee
wallywood and al hartley who wound up
leaving pussycat and marvel after
finding religion
he spent his remaining career drawing
christian-themed archie comics
it's easy to argue that stan's most
important role wasn't as a comic book
writer or
editor but as an ambassador for the
medium long before he was a notable
cameo in the world's most popular movies
he served his ambassador role with a set
of videos designed to give viewers a
look behind the scenes of the comic book
industry
released on vhs in 1991 the comic book
greats was a 12-part documentary series
hosted by lee where he interviewed
creators about their process
not only did it feature legends like
batman co-creator bob kane
it also put the spotlight on some of the
hottest creators of the era
among the most interesting segments are
stan's interviews with jim lee
todd mcfarlane rob liefeld and wills
portacio
four of the artists whose incredible
success in marvel would lead them to
found image comics
mcfarland and lifefeld's interviews even
managed to feature obscure first
appearances of characters that would
later make their way into the comics
challenged by stan to create a whole new
hero or villain on a tight time limit
lyfeld drew diehard a future member of
his super team youngblood
and quickly had a cheerful stan asking
questions about what he called our new
character
stan always had a knack for following
trends so it's no surprise that in 1998
he co-founded a company called stan lee
media in order to produce
webisodes for an internet audience
including an animated comic about the
backstreet boys
i hate when that happens it also
shouldn't be surprising that in 2000
when the dot-com bubble burst
slm went defunct and filed for
bankruptcy what happened after that
however nobody saw coming
the short version is that slm claimed
that lee assigned all of the rights to
his characters to the company and
they've been suing marvel
disney and lee himself for billions of
dollars since 2007. do what i ask
for earth and your friends are doomed
it probably goes without saying but the
lawsuits and appeals have consistently
been called frivolous and dismissed in
court
lee himself did his best to extract
himself from both the company and its
ongoing legal mess
unfortunately the one thing that isn't
in dispute is that they own the name
stan lee media linking lee's name to
their actions despite his best efforts
to shut them down
ah forget it the ups and downs of stan
lee's career aside he co-created and
helped introduce some of our favorite
characters to the world
with the help of late great legends like
jack kirby and steve ditko stan lee made
the fantastic four
spider-man the x-men iron man thor black
panther the hulk
and many other iconic characters
household names as the marvel cinematic
universe is starting to eclipse its
printed counterparts in terms of pop
culture influence and recognition
we should remember stan lee for being
the wonderful grandfather of superhero
dumb that he was
whether it was being the ambassador to
the comic book industry or giving peter
parker amazing advice on screen
i guess one person can make a difference
enough said